Got it.
No, no, no, no, no.
Where are you guys?
You want to shoot this meat run?
She is the way going.
Run, run!
Oh my God.
Where are you guys?
Which one is fruit?
I started my, we haven't even introduced anybody.
We just went straight in it.
Hello everybody.
We are here playing Who phobia?
Who phobia, yeah!
My name is Doki.
We're jumping right into it.
You guys missed out the saddest deer limping I've ever seen.
It was so sad.
I know.
It's great.
Anyway, should we all introduce ourselves?
Like before.
Instead of being like, who the fuck are these people right
now?
Just a bunch of people yelling, no big deal.
No big deal, no big deal.
Who wants to go first?
I'll go, I'll go, I'll go.
No one was gonna say anything.
I was gonna say, guys?
Guys?
We are all dead, we're all dead.
We all just point to each other and we're like, Not it!
Stupid!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Would you like to explain your name?
in-game name too.
Oh, no, no, no, don't explain it.
It's funnier that way.
That's my, that's my, um, that's my government name.
Don't you know?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, so daddy's the last name?
Oh, my game crashed.
Great game, great game.
Great game.
It goes backwards.
Oh, so your first name is daddy, and then your last name is
at mercy.
It's like Mr. Mrs. Miss.
daddy he she we wombo oh i'll do an imposter hunt that's the
one where like everybody is a there's like lots of deers and
you gotta figure out which is the right deer yeah i was
watching the trailer apparently there's like there's like a
herd and you have to like pretend to be yeah yeah yeah okay
let's see all right i got you guys i invited you guys i sort
of accidentally made the match public so please get fast
before but who's actually playing this game well now that i
said that people are gonna buy the game that hopefully i'm
gonna make another public lobby you're welcome for the free
advertising not sponsored by the way yeah not sponsored i
was like early access hold on what is this music Yeah, what
do you mean?
It's called Hunter Pride.
Art drop.
The music is killing me.
It was going crazy on the benjo.
The trailer is like orchestral music.
It's kind of funny.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We're organized.
We're so organized.
We haven't even finished introducing ourselves.
Let's get the game out.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these deers.
Fonlon Park!
Wait, I didn't mean...
I think we just...
Oh my god, it's just like nada in Japan.
Okay.
Who is...
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Who is the deer?
Yeah, guys, who's the deer I wonder?
What is it?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Shut up!
Oh my god!
You shut up!
Taking a shot!
You should be taking the shot!
The deer!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Before we get to it, do this, I guess.
Yeah, you should probably...
Wait, you killed me so hard that my stream died.
Oh my god!
Man, I killed a game.
I killed a stream.
Stream died?
Wait, where did she go?
Where did she...
Where did she go?
I'm scared.
I think I know where she is.
I think I...
No, she doesn't know.
Wow!
That's okay!
Goodbye.
That's so loud.
It's terrifying.
Who is the deer?
Did he get the wrong one?
No!
Oh, that was a loud gunshot.
Mine's sanity.
I think I'm dead.
guys oh my god i've been shot oh no are you lifting oh my
god you killed a deer oh that's basically what it looked
like when you get the deer it's the saddest thing ever look
at it don't mind me wait your neck has been completely yeah
yeah wait wait wait look look you wanna you wanna finish
No!
Don't worry!
I'm a hero!
Oh my god, Jesus!
I got you!
Don't worry!
There's no way she's gonna miss!
She's gonna miss!
Get him up!
Get over here!
Behind the tree!
Stop moving!
I got you!
Just oh god, okay.
Okay, she can't shoot me.
I have tree as a cover.
Are you short?
I told you!
She can't aim behind the tree.
Okay.
Wait, I'm just gonna...
I got no aim assist by the tree.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, here we go.
I got you.
There you go!
I got you!
They didn't even give me a chance!
Just keep standing behind the tree.
Don't worry, no.
I'm trying.
You're trying so hard.
Oh, there's a deer body blocking.
There you go.
Guys, you have to keep running.
I'm going to tear through my eyes.
I got him.
Okay, get closer.
Get closer.
The tree will save us.
Moose.
time oh my god okay all right all right all right i'm gonna
get closer get closer to the tree get closer okay i got you
i got you too distracted you get free
oh my god oh yeah you're gonna miss again
You want to play the swings?
You want to play the swings, guys?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
I'm standing, I'm standing.
What is this?
What the hell is that?
You were like wheeling.
What's up?
You've never seen a deer stand on two feet.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you never saw that.
All right, don't worry, Chad.
I lowered the game.
Holy shit.
This is the game of the year.
This is...
Game of the year, Goody.
All right, quick, before the game starts, go!
Quick!
Oh, my God.
Wait, who's the...
Oh, okay.
Who are you?
Oh.
You'll never know who it is.
Oh, oh.
Why am I first person?
This is the worst.
Whoa.
Who is a deer?
I'm...
saw you and i'm the one with the gun oh god damn it don't
want you
that's right quick come over here behind the tree that works
every time
Oh my god, my neck, what the freaking- I'm tickling his
toes, I'm tickling his toes!
There's no way you can't hit me!
I'm tickling your toes, I'm tickling your toes!
That's why you have to reload, but I'm stuck in the- No!
Frick!
Oh yeah, sorry, we forgot to introduce ourselves again.
We're all so distracted.
by the deer.
The only person that's been introduced is Have Mercy Daddy.
Yeah, yeah.
Have Mercy Daddy.
I'm not even honored.
Oh my god.
He killed all the skin walkers.
Oh god.
Alright, alright.
Before we start shooting, let's introduce ourselves.
Let's introduce ourselves.
I'll go, I'll go.
Hello, it's me.
Have Mercy Daddy, aka Omelie.
Hello, hello.
I am a voice actor and VTuber.
Nice to me.
you may have heard me in anime or video games such as my
dress of darling as marine or utah in one piece film red
among many others as me wow wow we have mercy daddy with us
we have mercy daddy we daddy of mercies wow wow no mercy
will be halved in this deer game I sure won't.
Wait, who has the gun now?
Not me.
I think it's fruit.
No.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
I think.
All right, fruit, since you have the gun and could kill us
at any moment, who are you?
Yeah, I totally have a gun.
Hello, I'm Avricad, also known as fruit, and I am a
part-time frog.
Part-time frog?
When did you become a frog?
Since I could go...
That's why she's part-time.
She's still interning right now under the frog ship.
I'm an intern.
I'm a frog intern.
Frog intern.
All right.
Okay.
Hello, everybody.
I'm Doki, aka Doki Bird.
That's it.
There's nothing else.
Good.
Red intro.
Start him simple.
I'm Sayu.
I'm a V-Tuber, voice actor, and other things.
I've been in Genshin as Sino.
If you want to hear a dad joke, I got a dad joke book here.
All right, hold on.
Did you hear about the cowboy with dietary restrictions?
He was rooting, tooting, free of gluten.
god i have uh fans have given me two versions actually i
have another book of these uh and yeah that's that's me i've
wasted other things but you can look it up but yeah hello
i'm here to uh kill the hunter today or you know kill some
deer depending on what we're who i'm playing as your team
hunter despicable oh my how dare you do you hate deer
It's monarch?
I can't believe it.
Where are you going?
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
You're at the wrong- Oh, you're at the wrong territory,
fucker!
Oh, my God.
Guys, rebuke me.
Please, I'm lifting him in the bush.
Get in the bush.
I'm in the bush.
Look, look.
Statue to the bush!
I'm okay!
You can't aim in bushes!
Wait, wait!
Idiot!
Revive!
She's in the bush!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I'm not okay!
Wait, did you die?
I don't know!
I'm still alive, but I'm not okay!
Why is this scary music?
What is happening?
Yeah, stupid!
Oh, that's like full insanity I get now.
Oh, hunter insanity.
I was like, what's that countdown?
What's the deer in my ears?
Oh, if you don't kill the deer fast enough, the deer become
sentient.
That's right.
The deer evolves.
The other deer?
We're gonna grab your gun and we're gonna shoot you.
That's right.
Oh, let's see.
True story.
Oh, fruit's the hunting.
Fruit's the hair.
Yeah, it ends up talking.
You know what?
I hate more than deer on this place.
What do you hate more than deer?
It could be any of us, fruit.
We could be right behind you right now.
And it's the scariest thing I've ever heard in my life.
We could be right to your left.
Are you following me?
That could be us.
Right now.
I could be right there.
Oh my god.
Holy crap.
This is scarier than lethal company.
Who's the app?
Who's here?
And who's the imposter?
I wonder if I can fix my FOV.
Oh, no, don't know.
There's no FOV settings.
I checked.
There's no...
You think this game has FOV settings?
This game has like...
Oh, shit.
You died?
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I tried to rush her.
Stand behind a tree!
Get behind a tree!
Don't worry!
Oh shit!
Okay, she doesn't know.
She doesn't know.
If I was a guy on you, what the frick?
Don't worry.
Don't worry, she didn't know.
App.
Oh.
Staying to the corner, I see.
Stand behind the tree, Emily!
What are you doing?
I can hit my footsteps behind me.
It's so scary.
Close this tree.
The bushes, yeah, the bushes work.
The bushes were...
Okay.
Hey, I wonder if that's suspicious at all.
I'm shooting you.
Oh my god, relax!
Relax!
Oh my god, Jesus Christ!
I got you!
Oh my god!
The sanity!
It's crazy now!
We have no other choice.
Get it.
Oh, you pushed me.
You surrounded.
Surround me.
You pushed me.
You're bullying them.
Bully them.
I need to reload.
Holy crap.
Bro, fruit, when you, when I hit you, I don't know what you
did, you flung me to the other side of a fucking map.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we'll do one more, one more of this game mode, because
there's like four games.
There's four games.
four different game modes oh wait why am i not doing it
again i can't leave the i can't my settings are broken i
can't leave at all i'm stuck in the settings it doesn't work
right i'm gonna be blind don't worry i'm blind oh i have my
ears i have my ears i have my ears i'm shooting everything
i'm like stuck in the Oh, you can't see us, can you?
No!
You want to bully a blind man with you.
I mean, we're doing that right now.
No!
I'm in bed.
Bullying.
You're not there.
That's right.
You can't see.
It's hunting season.
I'm in bed.
Wait, how did you die?
Don't worry, I got you.
I can't see anything.
I'm going to eat the grass.
No!
Hey, timing season!
Guys, I'm limping.
Please.
I'm like...
I'm stuck.
Please.
I'm like trying to play the game.
Sucks to be you, I guess.
You guys.
Provide me.
Eat the grass.
Eat the grass and I'll come back to life.
Oh!
Oh, you're going crazy!
It's time.
All I see is brown blurs.
I just eat brown blurs.
See this?
I need quests.
I love my quests.
I want to revive.
Happy you revive.
I want to upgrade.
I just press E.
Happy you.
I didn't want to.
E to revive.
I got two layers of settings.
Oh, no.
What exactly happened?
She got stuck in her settings page.
Yeah.
Cause I'm the.
I'm the.
In your settings page.
It's early access.
Are you still in the face?
Oh, yeah.
Comes near me, you're done.
Oh.
Yeah, but the more tears you kill, the crazier you get.
Oh, you're already almost crazy.
So you're saying I should just make y'all stand up.
Oh, fuck.
Whoa, whoa.
I'm not too shady on that cliff, Shady.
You think I don't see you in the bushes?
Yeah, that's fucking fun.
You can't aim for shit.
It's not that I couldn't aim.
It's just that I'm getting surrounded.
Oh, we're going to stand up soon, Sight.
We're going to be standing up soon.
Get away from me, you freaks.
Oh, that season looks different.
I want you to surround him.
I got stuck in a pumpkin.
Oh, you're crazy, Darren.
I'm going to be the only one side.
This is terrifying.
Yeah, this is so scary.
okay i'll start a new lobby okay okay so hunter insanity
it's like the more insane you are like they get up but then
if you get hit you're yeah yeah then you lose automatically
they have more hp too satya gotcha all right there is i
don't know what stay close is i think stay close is uh you
got a point if you're in proximity i think oh yeah yeah yeah
so you have to like figure out who is the right deer yeah
like if a deer is close to you yeah yeah yeah like if a fake
deer the skin walkers can i ask what inspired you to want to
play this look it's very hard to find multiplayer games sure
no no disagreement there but i'm just i saw this trailer and
i was like oh sweet this looks cool but then when it came
out there was no multiplayer it was like Yeah, it was like
there's no private server.
So I was like, okay, meet me another time and then I heard
they recently updated it with private servers And I was like
this is it.
This is my time to shine You're the one person in this on
steam you're like constantly checking it's like I'm waiting
Yeah, there's private servers you were the you were the one
target audience This is cast game of the this is gonna be
the next streamer game I can feel it.
It's just the entire community hub.
Last update was March 5th.
I'll give them that.
Big issue with the sound setting sliders, not having any of
that.
Wait a minute.
Guys, if the devs are watching this, please, we want
sensitivity setting.
Oh, yes, mouse sense.
Please.
I want outfits.
I want cosmetics.
You want cosmetics.
I want to give the deer a top hat.
Yeah.
yeah that's definitely gonna make sure that you know you're
definitely not the deer but they have to give random
cosmetics to the other deer the other dears have random
cosmetics i don't know what i'm supposed to do here a deer
with a clown nose oh we have to go to the hunter you see the
big beam in the sky like moving around oh oh sorry uh i'm
i'm where's the honey busy oh somebody's already got
somebody's already close to you oh or am i lying
i'll never tell those are my footsteps i get instead my own
footsteps but i know i'll know of a deer's footsteps when i
hear you sound like the guy that did the voiceover for the
trailer oh really i watched the trailer and i thought there
was gonna be voiceover for the hunter because in the trailer
he's like you effing dear like i'm gonna get there is but
it's just so quiet it's so so quiet oh really yeah when you
like spot in he sounds a bunch of stuff but it's so quiet
all he has Where the fuck is he That's what I'm saying Where
are you deer hunting not sightseeing?
What's going on?
The moment side sees just one of us he's just gonna start
shooting he doesn't care He's just like deer spotted I'm
hunting deer.
I don't see any I don't see any fake deer.
Do you guys see any fake deer?
No, I don't.
Oh, maybe it's more so of like hiding next to him.
Like, we're...
Oh.
That's what the crouch button is for.
That's why there's so many trees and bushes.
Oh, yeah, there's a crouch button.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, it is.
We have to hide behind him.
We're being paranoid.
I see a deer across the forest just crouching.
What the fuck is that?
I wonder who that could be.
Like, look across the forest.
Look across.
You might see me.
Turn around.
I see you crouch spamming.
Oh no, that's that's that must be fruit.
Yeah.
It's like a tea bag.
Must be nice knowing where the deer are.
Yeah, like be nice.
I mean, just give us the coordinates.
Wait, I see.
Okay, wait, that's you.
Dude, I can't even give you the coordinates if I wanted to.
Who the fuck is he?
One of us will find him.
Oh, sweet.
You're going to find him.
How close are you?
No, you see, look in the sky.
Look, look.
i'll see you guys oh he's close look at the sky he's
actually close by oh yeah there's there's like a thing in
the sky that shows where he is oh i see it like an alien i
see it yeah did you think he's wearing red oh my god we're
close i knew those deer were out of this world sigh we're
right by you we're next to you yes we are jump i don't need
to prove it oh i see a orange jacket.
You're aiming right down to the west.
We see you, son.
I actually don't like that.
I don't like that.
I don't like it.
Why are you running?
Why are you running, son?
Wait a second.
Hold on.
Oh, what are you doing?
Oh, I see you.
You're looking to the right.
You're looking see if the sound effects were the same as a
deer running.
Like if I ran, if they're the same sounds as deer running.
What are you running to the right?
I don't like this game.
We could be anywhere.
We could be in front of you.
We could be behind you.
You know what's the worst part?
There's like a radius around me that is clearly that thing
you guys are talking about.
You can see in like it when i zoom in it blocks out some of
the stuff so i can't even see oh oh my god he oh my god i'm
back he's getting crazy get in get in get in get in the
circle
that's so we can come back Oh, wait, I respawned.
Yeah, you can't kill us forever.
We come back.
These deer are fucking crazy.
Oh, don't keep moving.
No, we can be in front of you.
You don't know that.
I already be right next to you in a bush.
Yeah, get in a circle, get in a circle!
Get in a circle!
Oh, I sneaked right there.
right in.
Oh, don't you?
Yeah, that's right.
You don't give a terrible shot.
That's right.
You don't know where we are now.
My chance, like, five nights in the forest.
We're right behind you.
Oh, God.
That's terrifying.
Oh, you sigh.
I don't like this game anymore.
you it's like the slender meant the eight pages collected
eight pages maybe if i get high ground where is he oh no
wait no it's only five minutes who won how do you know who
wins that you won because you we didn't get to we didn't
make you go crazy we just made you yeah we just made you
slightly paranoid
Yeah, man, I killed that shit.
You feel an anxious, you feel an anxious.
To be fair, the first half of this was us figuring out how
to play.
Yeah, true.
Don't worry, guys.
If I'm a...
Okay, I know how to troll.
I'm here.
Oh.
I know what I'm doing.
You know what the...
Yep.
Sight looks like.
Yeah.
Yeah, now we know.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
I'm in my gamer chair.
I'm in my gamer position.
Did you put your glasses on?
You gaming?
need him i'm hunched over i'm ready i'm ready i see where
right next to you where oh you would like to know where
she's coming right for us she's coming right to us oh we
gotta make her go crazy oh my ass oh she missed she missed
she doesn't know where i am anymore after that bro let me
play she doesn't know she's scared i see you running back
and forth back and forth what i see you that's right oh my
god that's it i'm good where am i Where am I?
I've been doing it!
I'm
locked!
You're locked in!
You can't do all this!
She's going to send it!
Kill me!
Guys, don't worry!
She can't aim right here!
Oh, the hunter in Sanity respects whenever they Kill a deer.
Guys, we worked so hard, guys.
We had to die now.
I see now.
Oh, I fixed it.
I fixed it.
We figured this out.
She just turned to me.
Holy crap.
Guys, we worked so hard getting that meter up, guys.
We have to be more stealthy.
Believe.
So this really is a stealth game.
Where are you guys?
Come out.
Come out wherever you are.
Please.
I have a family.
I have a family of deers.
Please.
You wouldn't kill the father of Bambi now, would you?
Oh, I 100% would.
He's an asshole.
What do you mean?
Have you not seen Bambi, too?
I think I'm like the one person that saw Bambi too.
I am one of those people that watch Bambi too.
Are you running?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm gonna run in a circle!
Serpentine!
Oh, it's working!
They can't see me.
What am I, a Gator?
Oh, shit!
Wait, where are you here?
Oh, it would be great to have faked these on this map.
Yeah, but there's lots of bushes, though.
Mushes.
We have the bushes for cover.
I think we might have glitched the Hunter and Jami.
No!
No, it lost us the points!
Holy shit.
This one's harder.
The reset is hard.
Why are you hiding in that bush, Monarch?
But then if we all hide in bushes, she can't see us.
The hunter becomes the hunted.
Why are you hiding in that bush?
What?
The hunter becomes the...
How did you know?
I saw your little booty.
My little booty.
I saw your little pickles.
Surely she can't see me, Jet.
well I know for sure you're not in the circle you can't see
me chat there's no way there's no way oh we go I know we
could do this do what do you do what you do it away from me
you want to rip this game guys don't forget don't forget
guys we can crouch she can yeah yeah she can shoot though
it's okay she doesn't know standing in the open i got
launched oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
What's funny is I'm like spammy reload every time I'm in the
shadows.
Is it working out?
She hasn't got me yet.
Bro, she's so paranoid.
I'm shaking.
I'm shaking in my boots.
Bro, it's like she every Saturday she goes out and her deer.
This is not an amateur.
She definitely killed Bambi before.
yeah she's a bambi killer i can feel it that's not she's a
prodigy she got me apex legends baby dude i i actually do
think we may have glitched the insanity a bit no no no wait
wait up a little bit i saw it go up a little bit we just
keep dying a little bit okay there's 20 seconds on the clock
just to test it out monarch don't kill us let's just be in
the circle all in the open just No, she ran past me.
She ran past me, so I got a little bit.
We're just helpless little deer.
We're helpless little deer.
We just want to talk.
Oh, okay.
Well, I just want to talk.
Talking's over.
That one is hard.
Wait, why is the insanity going up?
We're not even fucking playing the game.
Did we spawn?
I was just thinking, like one of us spawned into the circle
in the loading scene.
I was locked in, baby.
What?
I'm the killer again?
Alright, alright, alright.
We just want to talk.
Use flashlight!
There's a flashlight!
Wait, there's a flashlight?
Yeah, it's F.
I'm glitched in the grass.
This is it.
This is our chance guys.
She's glitched.
We could win.
Go go go go go She's stuck Go go go.
Yeah, don't see any.
Oh, I see her.
Don't you worry.
My stream froze once I get on the other computer Oh, yes,
yes It's a shame You hear that?
Flip-clop clip-clop clip-clop clip-clop clip-clop I think
it's like dear T6 go man we're I can't see shit you will
never see anything I need grass is so thick get out the tall
grass before the Pokemon comes for you Ow!
Nice shot!
Whoa!
No!
I swear to God!
Don't die!
We'll lose our points!
The sand!
The grass!
We're so close!
Wait, we can't like climb up!
I ran away!
Friend!
Don't die!
Our points!
Just hide in the grass!
I gotta go to Candy Mountain!
Come on, boy!
The water's so loud!
Dude, the water is extreme!
Extremely loud That's it.
That takes her more parents.
Where am I?
Where am I now?
We almost got this!
You should have got the wild grass when you had the chance
You better run.
Yes, right So wait, what happened?
I was like a foot tall.
I was like an ant.
She couldn't see past the wild grass.
You know what I'm doing?
An animated movie?
Oh, when you lost?
No, that whole time.
The whole game.
Yeah, because she was so, she was too short for the tall
grass.
You know, like in Pokemon?
Like, what?
Well, it looks like it's my turn, fellas.
Oh, your turn.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
Oh, it's daytime.
That's cheating.
You get the sun to your advantage.
I gotta find me in open field.
Oh, no.
Don't let him get the open field.
I hear you.
Well, yeah, you do.
In the bushes.
Yeah, you hear definitely hear me in the bushes.
I have an idea.
You're still not in the open field.
I'm trying.
Oh, I know you're here.
Oh, no, you don't.
Yeah.
No, you don't.
I know you're in when I hear the timer.
When you hear the timer.
Don't worry.
There's bushes all around you.
How did you see the force wheel?
Yes, walk.
I didn't see it.
I was like, where did he go?
Also, it didn't reset.
So...
Oh, that was a bug on the other map.
Clearly, I just...
Early Axis.
I mean, this is pretty good for an early Axis.
You hear that?
Oh yeah, it works now.
Yeah, that's right.
You capped 360.
They made it so much easier for you guys.
You can't say that!
I'm gonna fuck yours up!
I can't you be more like I'm a Liza Whoa Wait, I'm stuck
Wait, no, wait, it's a dead end Oh, she was dead end This is
a dead line No!
Why me?
I just got here Oh no, we died too many times it resets Oh
no Well, well, well Look at you, I bet it's here No If it is
the consequences of our own This round We can get it back
up.
You can.
Oh, this is like a...
That's right.
Try and shoot this.
You can't leave this.
This is an invisible wall.
I'm out of ammo.
Oh, you are?
He's reloading.
He's reloading!
Out of ammo, we go in for the kill.
I'm a Halo player, not an Apex player.
It's okay.
He can't shoot the tree.
Just like last time.
Battle divers!
Oh no!
For democracy.
We're still in here.
But you don't know where.
Yeah, where could we be, I wonder.
Oh, where could we be?
What?
You're lucky I had to reload, you damn.
Sure.
Shall I find an issue?
It's okay.
For democracy, you of a bitch.
Tick tock.
Yeah, yeah, you're still in here, huh?
It's like playing dodgeball.
I've always been in here.
If you can dodge a bullet, you can dodge a ball.
What do I look like?
Wait, don't shoot me, but what do I look like?
What the frick is happening to me?
Is her neck all twisted?
Oh my god, you look like a spider deer.
No!
I said don't shoot Don't let me in There were too many
people yelling Oh no it's a don't Don't bounce I couldn't go
anywhere Well I can't believe it Sigh is exploiting He's
exploiting Exploiting And don't blame me for the game making
On an invisible wall Mons Mons This ain't democracy!
You're right.
This is a dictatorship.
No.
Oh, damn.
What are you looking at right now?
Maybe that jumped in the air over there.
No!
Can't catch me at 360!
Oh dear!
I took you right.
That's right!
You ran out of ammo!
Oh my god!
I got one bullet left one bullet left no more bullet oh I
used to reload no he has to cool down nice we got it oh my
god what happened to my body my body oh no the game said
stop explaining no stop working the timer stop working he
stopped going crazy he's becoming sane oh no no no he's
going crazy again that's good guys we can't let him kill us
the meter's going up against the tree.
I'm stuck.
What was going on here?
You'll never know.
That's right.
You in the wrong territory.
What happened to my body?
I'm in the wrong negative woods now.
Yeah, that's right.
I was thinking right.
Get out of here.
What?
Yes, get it!
No!
You some bitch.
I got one of you.
Oh, you did it.
Well, you missed.
Yeah, that's for Bambi!
I'm going up the map!
That's for Bambi!
Chat, they're cheating!
We can't talk grasshopper.
You literally won.
I still won.
No!
I'll never give you.
I found out Ping is the thing.
Bro, on my end, I literally was under the map.
I'm like, what's going on?
He like disappeared from me.
I was like, where did he go?
Oh, I think the night maps are the scariest.
Yeah, for sure.
It's gonna make me the hunter.
I wonder what the what?
no what did you say oh i wonder what the proximity chat
sounds like like is it just the deer running by like the
funny thing is it's like one of those things where i like
looked and there's no way to pick what microphone to use in
the game unless you have to do it specifically in your
settings i can't see i can't see anything i can't see
anything i just hear it just hear me right beside you Come
on, Froo.
Be Apex.
Oh, we're right here.
I can't with this high sense.
Hey, guys.
Can you hear me?
Oh, my God.
I was flying.
I'm in the mouth.
I don't think you're near us.
Are you near us, Say?
Fast.
Hold on.
I don't see you.
Text.
Proximity chat.
Oh, no.
No, we don't hear you.
I don't think you're near us.
I'm right behind you.
Wait, you're right, boys?
No, I don't hear you.
Well, proximity chat is a lie.
update don't worry actually add proximity chat we're the
early pioneers that's right go on me okay my oh my aim
doesn't work my aim's broken guys it's broken it's broken i
broke the game i broke the game i broke the game it happened
to me just zooming it out oh this is so trippy
Apex.
Oh, the sniper shot.
I literally broke the game.
Yo, she broke the game.
There's a chance for us.
There's a chance.
What are you spawning at the edge of the fucking map?
I can't, I can't like ADS anymore.
You can't ADS.
Oh, no.
It's broken.
No!
Oh, my God.
What?
Water is so loud.
That's why we need to take her to the water.
only chance when you take her into the water all right push
her to the water fruit you know where you want to go come on
fruit go to the water fruit come on go to the tall grass hey
guys hey guys go to the top to your left i don't know how to
i don't know how to swim yeah come on this way follow us
fruit i don't know how to learn fruit if you want to be a
full frog you want to be a full the coat of the water oh
that's true that is true brebt it's right here it's calling
my name it's calling your name just like the rainbow
connection oh oh you're almost there fruit I can't shoot you
even if I wanted to because I cut ADS into the water to the
water so close just head straight down to your left I am
fruit to your left you're going away from the water there is
great I can't see you.
If you're going away from the water.
Have you tried pressing F?
Yes!
It's worse!
Try, um...
What worked for me was zooming in and out, like, using the
scope again.
I was like, what's in this bush?
And I just see, like, a huge...
okay we'll put you out of your misery miles away i am yeah i
like being a million miles away what the there's like some
maps are like tiny as fuck and then this one is like 200
miles away from the honey like what honey
she's got that Hunter.
At Apex Legends.
You're going to open field?
What is this?
You're in the fucking corner.
I just hear the shots.
I'm like 200 meters away.
I'm within all these bushes.
Wish is the right bush.
Whoa.
Fruit, what are you doing?
I don't know.
I'm so paranoid right now.
I'm so scared.
Hey, how's it going, pal?
How's it going, pal?
Wait, I'm stuck.
Oh my god, my W key doesn't work.
That's it?
She's stuck.
We got this.
You lied.
You lied to me.
I didn't even do anything.
Hey, I don't need a W key to shoot.
Damn, that's crazy.
I was just watching your back.
And this is the thanks I get.
I'm gonna reload.
You're jumping in so funny.
You're jumping in the funniest looking thing.
Come on, fruit.
Don't do this.
This is not like your fruit.
You wouldn't kill a deer, would you?
You wouldn't kill a deer with glasses, would you?
You wouldn't download a deer, would you?
Oh my god, my god.
Wait, I died and my scope is perma- I'm perma-scope dead.
I'm perma- God damn it.
No!
We're so close!
The scent is alive!
That's lucky, right?
She doesn't know.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, don't walk away from the bushes.
Come on.
Fruit doesn't know.
You don't know.
I don't know.
Come on, we're just...
Wait, I don't.
I'm stupid.
We're just shit.
Every time we get close, she shames us.
That's right.
That's like you're right.
Back into the bushes.
I go.
No!
Wait, I found them.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the closest we got was getting Amalie crazy.
That's the closest we ever got.
Will I ever get to be the hunter?
Have you ever been?
No, I've been zero times.
I've never got chance to be a hunter.
It really hates you.
Can the host not be the hunter?
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe that's why.
That would make a lot of sense.
I say as I'm the hunter.
I'm the hunter now.
All right, fellas.
I'm going to bully the shit out of Doki Bird.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
Bro, the flash like fucking sucks.
What the fuck?
Yeah, it's so bad.
It's so bright.
Oh, hey, deer and headlikes?
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, I understand
now.
I understand now.
Hey there, pal!
Please, I'm sorry for bullying all deers before.
Oh, no, oh, no.
This is for my cousin Bambi!
To me!
Join Bambi in heaven!
I'm sorry.
thanks oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh my god now i know
now i know oh my god it's like a fucking flashbang every
time oh there's so many of you oh my god you should see how
funny the 360 jumping is no oh god where's the other deer
why are you jumping Jumping, I live here.
If I jump, maybe you won't clip my hitbox.
Hold the sword.
Oh my god.
We keep moving.
They won't know.
Are you jumping?
I see you in the bushes.
I know you're in the bushes.
We're always in the bushes.
I know what to do.
Into the water and go.
That's pecking right!
I see you in there.
You're in that bush!
No!
I'm strafing!
Yes!
She's tap strafing!
That's pecking right.
I have aim assist.
Oh, I know you're near me.
Behind you.
No, dokie.
Behind you, dokie.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're not in my circle.
Maybe I'm in that bush right next to you.
There's a bush.
next to me there's no bushes next to me that's right you're
in an open field you see yeah that's okay right no no no no
there's too many trees there's too much trees that's we're
in the trees we're in the trees Looking good, Doki.
There's too many.
Looking good, Doki.
Oh, God.
Where are you?
No, I can't go.
Has the paranoia settled in yet?
It's okay.
One of you will go down.
As long as I bring one of you down.
Yes.
Oh, run.
Run.
Where are you running?
Away from you.
I see you.
I see you right there.
I see you to my left.
You think I don't see you now.
You're to my right You think I don't see you?
Are you sure that's me?
I'm pretty sure I killed the other two You're the only dear
left in the world.
I'll make sure you all go extinct Really you said because
I'm the one right in front of you.
Oh, you're serpentine.
I see you serpentine right now.
That's right.
I told you you weren't alone I warned you.
You know what?
I'm going to do a 360 no scope.
Where did you come from?
Yo!
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Did I hit anybody?
I didn't get the player.
Open field, huh?
Full strategy.
Reload, reload, reload, reload, reload.
yes you can do this fellas oh my god oh god oh god oh god
there's so many serpentines give me a lot there's a lot of
bullets firing oh god oh god oh my god please Bob and Weave,
boys.
There's so many of you.
Bob and Weave, boys.
Bob and Weave.
Oh, God.
I'm so far away.
Oh, I think so.
Wait, who left?
What happened?
There we go.
You all went way too quiet for this game.
Everyone just stopped laughing.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
You can run that fast.
Best maneuver.
Bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada.
Oh, the bobbin rose!
Oh, fuck!
And leave it alone!
This is the new cow tipping!
This is just our hobby!
Holy crap!
Leave it alone!
There's the new cow tipping!
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I always miss the one deer.
I get two.
Two is my limit.
Ah, fellas, I don't think we're gonna be able to do it.
Yeah, that's true.
not being stealthy that's for sure all right let's bully the
fuck out of here please I'm just doing
you're gonna be right oh my god dear hunter superior all
right we'll do it to the next game mode this is the next one
all right all right the next one is now that you said I've
never been hunter watch you be hunter like 10 times in a row
that's what's gonna happen oh no Hit and run.
Connection failed.
Well, right, right.
Because I think Doki has to leave everything.
Yeah, I was the host.
I switched game one.
Who wants to be the host?
Oh, wait.
Let's see.
Let's have Fruit be the host and see what it's like on EU
ping.
On EU ping.
Oh, really?
That's not EU ping.
Let me see.
This will go swimmingly.
Oh, no.
That's okay.
As long as we're not hungry.
be fine as long as we all have oh god no the 200 ping 200
ping on eu servers there is a single player mode by the way
how the fuck is there a single player mode the deer so
they're all imposter yeah you can't trust nobody i said i
said oh i got it i said you i got it i don't have Can we
add?
Maybe we can add them to the party.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can.
I can invite.
Oh, nice, nice, okay, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, well, I confirmed for a future.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What are we seeing?
This is a great, this is a great game.
Good job.
Yeah, good job.
Add more game modes.
Wait, give us more setting options, please.
No, more game modes.
What if there was like a backroom?
It's Deers, but the backroom?
Party leader matchmaking.
Wait, are they making?
Oh, wait, you're supposed to do...
Create match.
Create a match.
Oh.
Yeah, I didn't invite us again.
I love how there's deer emotes.
I can't wait for the cosmetics.
The deer.
Yeah, yeah.
One, two, and three.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I found that.
Was that how you guys were shaking your booties?
Yes.
Yeah.
That's how you shake the booty.
I was wondering.
Eat the grass.
Yep.
up all right that's incredible i'm in i'm in hit and run
let's go let me in let me in get an air a good old banjo yep
let's do this i can't wait to put the deer ready up i can't
wait to put our little hats on i'm ready for democracy
democracy let's go
hi we're going to school we're going to school high school
for tears so oh brother hit and run is this like dvd is
there an inside and outside oh i wonder i'm eating the grass
right now you don't know where i'm in this court you say oh
so we have to stay outside of the bubble but you have to hit
the the hunter wait it's just us i just realized it's just
us us oh that's right oh what the where is he oh my gosh
it's so low there's like a little boss oh yeah oh that's
right that's right that's right you don't know
Where I am.
Oh.
You don't know where I am.
I'm like in my kill.
Don't skin me, please.
You don't know where I am.
No, I'm getting skinned.
But escape.
We have to escape the boundary.
Oh, my God.
You just kicked someone.
All right.
I'm out.
I got some point.
Nice.
I'm stuck.
Wait.
Ow.
Who are you all around?
Oh my god What happened?
Oh my god.
Oh Oh, do we have to stay in the bubble?
Oh, no No, he killed all of us.
No He double tapped.
Oh, why?
He double tapped me And now I'm gonna skin you.
Oh, what the fuck dude?
Well, good thing I blend in with the ground.
Oh shit, I hear like spot.
So you went to stay in, went to stay in.
for the point what to say is oh no can't get me escape no no
we have to say no wait we lost
i you looking this way it's right that's right you can't
shoot i know this i noticed you can't See
That's a cure
Got it got point got point If you excuse me, I'm skinny my
prey.
If you if you excuse me, I'm trying to skin my I'm trying to
skin my I'm trying to You're never gonna skin I did it No,
Fred, no!
Don't let him skin me!
I'm a skinner.
Holy crap!
Don't let him do it!
My skin is worth so much money!
I'm done.
No, it ain't.
I was like, what are you doing?
You can see me?
You can see me now?
Oh, I just... Fred, you let it do me!
Give me your flesh.
We gotta fight, we gotta fight, we gotta fight.
I'm scared.
Can you see the beer?
Through what?
No!
Okay.
Where is he?
He's over there.
I'm a parked car.
Boom!
How the fuck?
That's right.
I was always behind you.
Wow.
You're lucky I'm a bad shot.
You guys are lucky I'm a shit shot.
I'm glad I'm not the honky.
I just got up, baby.
Damn.
Yeah, that's right.
You're gonna get bullied.
You're gonna let yourself get bullied by a herd of deer.
Wait, if you hold space.
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
Hey.
Whoa, that's right.
You let that three.
That's three.
He's been fucking crying.
I'm trying to skin you, but it won't let me.
That's looking right now.
Oh my god, I look horrific.
What the hell?
Don't worry, guys.
Another point.
I realized Sight has two people when you're three CCing.
I got shot.
Hello.
I can't.
Oh, I'm reloading all right.
Where am I going?
Hello?
The game is broken.
What's going on?
The game looks like...
The skin looks really graphic.
It's okay.
Where's with you?
E!
You can't eat anymore.
Okay.
No!
It's so close.
He got a triple.
We're winning though.
He can't skin us all.
us all in time i responded what he missed out he missed out
on my skin excuse me i'm trying to skin my catch that's
right no you are no skinnier cashier
now you don't know where i am i think i can't move my camera
he's in the open he's in the open
that's right you don't know i'm in the bushes i'm a bushman
get off me oh wait can we not knock you over when the the
thing is up i think if you already knocked him once you
can't do it again that's right don't we got you you got you
wait you skinned one and then it ran away wait you skinned
the wrong one and skinned the one a live one but you still
skinned you skinned Oh my god, I'm so fucked up!
I'm so fucked up!
This game dog!
It's just getting the closest to you!
Oh my god!
My true form.
Oh, where is he?
Where?
Where could the hunter be?
Who's the hunter?
Who is it?
Who could it be?
Yeah, I wonder.
Aren't you having a great time, bro?
Oh, no, you can't hide from that tree.
You can't hide from that tree.
Yeah, that's right.
Wait, this tree is back.
Oh, shit.
Don't let her near me.
She doesn't know where I am.
She doesn't know where my body is.
Guys.
No.
And double-tapped me.
Don't eat my body.
Please.
She's not getting near my body.
She can't get the point.
Don't let her get that point.
Don't let her get close to me.
Don't let her touch me.
Don't let her.
Zero point for you.
Yeah, you better run.
You better run.
I was so fast.
You're tired.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's a little bit crippled, man.
I was on your ass for a good five minutes.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
That's it.
Yes.
That's right.
You catch.
You know what?
Come on.
Try to shoot me here.
Oh my gosh.
That's right.
Try to shoot me through.
Come on.
360.
Oh, that's a lot of wasted ammo there.
I got it lost, dude.
That's a lot of wasted ammo.
Guys, guys, don't let her touch me.
Guys, please, my...
Don't let her touch me, I didn't consent to this!
Don't let her skin be allowed!
No!
It is cool!
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, my skin!
My beautiful skin!
My flesh!
The bubble is...
Oh, look at this.
Yeah, you gotta, like, stay in...
You gotta, so you gotta, like, hit, like, the hunter.
Stay inside the circle.
And then you gotta stay in the boundary.
And then after...
Oh, shit!
Oh!
you guys traded yeah you have to like make sure you kill the
deer that hit you so they can't get the point i can't see
anything that's good yeah more points for us did you know
that as a deer there's a suicide button yes wait what is
this oh wait there's a bug the deer right here no no there's
no
I miss my open meadow.
I want to go home.
I miss my open me.
No, don't worry.
I'm not going to show you home.
I'm going to go home.
We know you're here.
The moment you get up, you're going to get shot again.
Enter that bush is on the boat.
Oh, no, my ADS broke again.
It's perfect again.
That's right.
Good.
You shouldn't have told us.
that free points for us where are you sons of benches oh no
where are we i smell you i smell you skip the belly i got
another point you're looking at my idiots don't work you
don't need it food you're i need it don't be restricted from
i need it i don't spit oh it doesn't work it doesn't Don't
you know who you're better than this.
Slapping to the sun drip.
Come on, you only got three of us.
Come on, fruit.
My head is sticking out.
Oh, my head is not sticking out anymore.
Dude, fruit, in the last one, you literally walked over to
my body like twice.
Whoa.
Before you get back, cat, come on, come on, come on, fruit.
Yeah.
I got an idiot to see that.
No, he can see that in my butt.
foot popped out of the bush no please don't let it get me
guys don't let it touch my skin that beautiful skin hey i'm
sorry i'm trying to get us points oh yeah how many points
did you get huh huh sigh how many points i'm pretty sure
like four or five i know get back here i'm about to
It was my friend Don't worry Get these out bushes Do I got
you I'm gonna stop you Don't let it double tap I got you I
didn't even hit you I got no audio So I can't do anything I
can't do anything I did that Man that sure sucks Your skin
got ripped off Man that's crazy Could be me Dog I can't do
anything I'm not good Man your skin Go off that shit's wild
Oh my gosh No Don't double tap You could say it You could
say it was buck wild That was What the fuck is that in here?
I'm hearing stuff.
Hey, what's good, fellas?
Head on my knee.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna be right here.
Shit.
Guys, I think we're losing our touch, guys.
She's getting better.
She's improving.
Oh, she's getting better.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
She's adapting.
Apparently, my last point didn't count.
I just want to let me know.
Adapted!
Oh!
She's doing it!
She's gaming!
She's using Apex!
I am so close!
Oh my god!
I literally rang!
I'm hipfire in the line!
Keep hitting her!
I could respawn if she won't get my skin!
I got it!
She got my skin!
Oh shit!
Top 10 fruit noises!
Here we go!
We did it!
Oh, we did it!
Oh, so close!
My skin would have been peeled off, but I'm...
I won.
I was so close.
You can't catch us all through it.
You could.
I figured out the game too late.
Go to one too if it weren't for you.
You could just jump over my head.
That's the strat.
That's, oh no, not the night map.
Not the night map.
Not at night time.
I don't want to be hunter.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, brother, it's me.
ain't good oh sucks to be you sucks to be you sigh you got
it where are you i hear them oh that's it why do you get the
spot you'll have no son to help you now i hate him oh right
why'd you see that right in front of me yeah i got a little
coffee you don't know i'm in the dark no he knows He knew
now.
Let me skin you.
No, don't touch me, please.
Please.
It won't let me.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, no!
Look at that.
My beautiful skin.
I have a very long skin routine.
You ruined it.
Your beautiful coat.
No.
Yeah, your beautiful coat.
I will avenge you.
Will I make a pretty coat?
Will I...
Thanks for your flesh.
Ah, fuck that.
That was so close.
You almost saved me.
See him.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
We don't have any points.
We got up on game.
Get him.
That's right.
Dingle!
Guys, I got us some points, but not for us.
You tried.
Get on the ground and let me skin you.
No!
I didn't get us the points.
I got a single point.
We did it.
You're the clutch.
I'm not dancing shit.
The blue does not help, fellas.
That's great.
My Zoom does not work anymore.
That's right.
You got the fruit nerf.
I sure did.
That's like we're no scoping everything.
Gotta get higher at all.
Never mind.
My Zoom works now.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
We gotta beat him up.
Beat him up.
My camera doesn't work, by the way.
So I need to jump.
That jumps shot.
See, it's okay.
Don't let him near me.
Don't let him near me, guys.
Don't let him near me!
Someone hit him!
No!
Get out!
You some bitch!
We wouldn't let him near me!
Get him away from me!
He's gonna do it!
Get off of me!
Get off of me, you bastards!
Get off!
I can't believe you fucking disgusting deer!
Dude.
Yeah, that's right.
Deer together strong.
And this is some great age bullshit.
Oh, no!
Okay, guys, I realized running straight on it was not the
right idea.
You got a bob and a weave.
I didn't.
I didn't really bob and weave.
This map, guys, I think this map might suck as a hundred.
Wait, Really?
No way.
The insta skin?
Oh my god.
The night map is bad for the hunter?
No fucking way.
Who would have thought?
The bob and weave.
The bob and weave is pissing me off.
Bob and weave.
Whoa!
That's it!
That's it.
That was actually fucking hilarious.
What are you guys doing?
It's upsetting me!
There's no more stealth.
It's just bobbing weave.
I'm scared.
I'm hungry.
I just want my beer skin.
You're at that four.
Don't you have enough?
No, no, it's not for you.
It's four not enough for you.
Get over the minute.
No, fruit.
I'm not going to lie.
Here's the weird thing.
glitches so I don't even know where fruit's body is yeah I
can't move oh did you see me crouch back yeah yes I did
that's how he found you already I can't help you I have to
escape the battery it's for the great and good oh if you
hold space pretty pug give me your flesh boom there you go
that's right bob and weave time bob and wave bob and wave
boys smile and wave where do i go oh my god that's why i
didn't get that you know i gave you that point i i felt bad
for you i felt my e button isn't working so yeah that means
the buddy is just somewhere else no you can kill issue it
won't let me harvest it's a buddy is somewhere else this is
a skill issue i think are you maybe the game might you know
game might yeah just because you're bad at the game doesn't
mean a game yeah i'm pretty sure that's the definition of a
game suck you guys i think this game has been great so far
and i've been enjoying my time as you did i just said i got
stealth 100 stealth 100 right here yeah i see
Ow!
We have, we got, we got.
That's right.
Bro.
I only have half a point.
I love it.
I'm not even zooming in anymore.
I'm just doing it.
No!
It's looking kind of weird right now, guys.
This new season's smacking.
I like sail through this.
the map you're not getting any skin
you want to do one more than imposter one I think that one
was a fun game I'm so happy I got to hear my favorite fruit
noise which is
who's making that lobby who's making the lobby for for
imposter imposter oh someone else let me yeah yeah i can do
i can do i can do i can do okay create wait create match
wait yeah yeah yeah oh wait a second i think i fucked up
wait pause jump okay wait invite friends wait a second yeah
yeah yeah okay you get you got this you got this she's got
this she's got this you want to do what is believe i believe
I'm my own keyboard.
Wow, half mercy daddy invited me to some bullshit.
Wait, hit and run was not right.
Wait a second.
It's the, oh no, no.
Sorry, sorry, you're learning, you're learning.
You're getting better.
Hit and run, imposter.
Oh, I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, don't worry.
That one, that one is so fun.
This one you can use emotes.
I'm in.
I got this, gamers.
Don't worry.
but then they fucked up.
Oh, man.
On the first one!
I'm more important than all of you because I'm the first
one.
I got it.
You know, they say first is the worst, actually.
Yeah, well...
Second and third are better.
My atlas are bigger than yours.
Yeah, you want to prove it?
Yeah, there's so much testosterone right now.
I'm getting so much.
That's right.
Well, measure it.
You want to measure our antlers together.
I've got a huge pair of antlers right now.
My antlers are at least 10 inches.
Come on.
It's not about the size.
It's how you use your antlers, fellas.
Alright, alright.
It's the motion of the ocean, right, guys?
We can't even go in the ocean.
What are you watching about?
swim the school the school oh this is man i sure hope i
don't have a gun between my hands i mean hugs between your
hands oh i know the one deer that instantly ran i wonder if
that's no no i i have no idea whoa oh my god what's
happening no idea who that could be I have no deer.
I have no deer.
No, that's a fucking wrong deer.
Wrong deer.
I'm sure you can make it into a pun.
Slip me or slam jam idiot!
I'm outing!
Oh shit, so scary!
It's so scary!
I'm gonna fucking get you!
You ain't getting shit.
Oh my god.
Wait, you're already insane?
Oh, I shot one deer accidentally.
You're going to go insane.
No, no, no.
Just no way.
Come on, I know what it's one of you.
What is the countdown for?
I know one of you is the deer.
I know one of you is not real.
You're not real.
I took my meds today.
I know one of you is not real.
Is that...
Are you real?
Took your meds, you say.
Let's test that theory.
Oh, no.
Which one is it?
I was trapped in a room once.
Are you real?
A room full of deer.
Are you a real deer?
You're a real deer.
Oh no.
Who's not?
It's not real.
I can see them in my wall.
How do you know?
Everyone's a real deer until they're not.
Crazy.
I was crazy once.
Let me out, let me out.
Where even are you?
Grab the room full of deer.
You'll never know.
Oh my god, why are you following me?
Why is this the other one?
Two deer is following me.
Oh, there's a lot of deer is following me right now.
Are you spooked?
You know what?
I'm sick and tired of waiting.
Me too.
Run!
Get her!
Burn!
No!
I got rushed!
Someone call the evidence!
Oh no.
Snake maneuver!
No!
I'm going to reload!
Help!
No.
Where did he go?
Where did he...
There's no...
No!
That's not a real deal!
That's a real deal!
No!
Get away!
There's a few of them!
There's two of them!
What the?
Oh, fuck my ankles!
Oh, there's one left.
Oh my god!
Oh, guys!
This isn't terrifying enough!
Really?
Whoa Yes I did not die
Yeah Oh no I did I thought I took my men Is poop phobia a
real thing Bro It's like phasnophobia Yeah
I can't wait for the deer to appear in lethal company.
How tiny is your garden?
Now, hold up.
In lethal company, that actually would be terrifying.
Just ahead of a deer.
Chasing you down.
Locked in.
Oh my god.
I'm going to go insane.
This is an awful map.
Holy crap.
I really should.
You'll never know which one's the right one.
Which was the right deer?
Oh, which one is it?
Why are you staring at me?
That's why!
Yes!
No!
Don't get her!
I got stuck in the wood!
Guys, I got stuck on a tree.
Where's me?
That's right, that's right, there's no way he doesn't know.
He doesn't know, he doesn't know, he doesn't know.
No!
He doesn't!
It's after you!
I'm not heavy!
Just so you know, I am not walking towards Sai.
Just so you...
I think I killed Sai.
Just so you know.
I'm not walking towards Sai.
Oh shit!
In my defense, the tree trunk got in my way.
She did it!
She won!
The hunters!
That map is so hard.
That tree really fucked me over.
But my hoof got stuck on the branch and I couldn't.
I know.
I told you it's not about the size.
It's how you use it.
It got stuck.
My antlers were too big.
Who's running already?
I don't know who's running already.
Hey, is that Amelie right there?
Where?
I'm gonna shake my booty Shaking my booty right now You're
too close How did you come?
You're too close Oh inside Oh inside You're too close I'm
gonna shake my booty I have an idea Hey that's my joke You
can't I stole it You sure did What the fuck It's my name
What the joke Yeah Yeah Oh, you're so paranoid.
You're like, look, you're like...
It's like that, like, old man in the house is so paranoid.
You'll never get me, you son, bitches.
The government can't catch me.
That's why I never pay taxes.
I'm off the grid.
I'm going on the swimsuit.
Swing.
I don't fucking know anymore.
Shit.
Is it you?
It could be any of us.
There's so many of us.
Turns out you're all in the fucking bag.
See?
You're too close, man.
You're too close.
You're too close!
You're too fucking close.
No!
You had to wait!
There's a timer!
We can't kill him yet!
Oh no!
Oh, okay, okay.
It's okay.
We could get close to him again.
Oh, don't!
Just keep walking.
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'll walk.
I'll walk out of you.
I walked out of you.
Wait, there's...
I better not be you.
Why are you walking away?
That better not be you.
We don't know.
He's shooting random deer now.
He's shooting random deer.
He's nervous.
He's scared.
He's so scared.
Of course I fucking am.
I'm scared.
Paranoid.
He doesn't know which one's the right, dear.
Come on, come on, Sayu.
You love gotcha.
Just choose one.
Yeah, just choose one.
It could be any of us.
Come on.
It's all, it's all, you know what, the gotcha rates?
I think the gotcha rates is in your favor right now.
I know.
I've seen you pull.
You've been pretty lucky.
No, I have not.
Break, break.
Don't be a coward.
Take a shot.
That could be me right now.
Take the shot.
You're on the floor.
Take the other shot.
I'm like right texting you right now.
You should take the shot.
Test your gotcha.
Don't you want to look at my, you know, my...
Test the gotcha.
Look at all of us here.
Test the gotcha right now.
Test the gotcha.
Quick, quick.
Oh yeah, quick.
There's so many of us here.
Yeah, there's so many of us here.
He's here.
Take the shot.
I'm resting.
I'm resting right now.
You're not see me, Rezing.
You're not Rezing.
You are not Rezing at all.
You're not Rezing at all.
You're not see me, Rez.
You're not seeing me, Rez.
Wait, why did I keep getting the E to revive Khori?
Why did it so well?
Take the shot.
Take it.
Oh my god.
Nice gotcha, it is!
That was like, yeah!
Oh my god!
It was an early pull.
I still take that as a win.
Back to back five stars, that's crazy!
That's a win in my book.
That's my win.
Oh my goodness!
Oh!
Have we played on this one?
I think we did one.
Oh, we haven't.
Look, I think he got a pity there.
That was a pity pull.
And that 100% was hard pity.
Why me?
Oh, we know who it is now.
I'm scared.
A gun isn't enough to hold you back.
A gun isn't enough.
It's nighttime.
Welcome to the circus.
I just came to see a funny clown.
Well, come to the circus of value!
Oh, no.
In the end, it was you.
You were the clown.
Kill the clowns.
Where is she?
Wait, where is she?
I can't fight it.
I don't see her.
Why are you getting close to?
Who are you?
Oh, I see her.
Oh, I see her, too.
Stay away from me!
I'm right next.
Come out, come out, wherever you are.
Look behind you.
Look behind you, fruit.
Why are you running?
Oh my god, he's true screams.
Holy shit.
That's so scary.
Oh my god.
I'm in the woods.
I'm behind a tree right now, watching your every movie.
movement wait there's another trace i'm watching your friend
oh this might be so hard yo i love what you back yourself
into a corner
i'm looking at you why are you running to the left fruit why
are you running i start with something over here right
you're going to the light you're going to let you hear those
hoof steps right now this is a horror game i'm not even
joking that's right why is it so dark holy crap it's so dark
i'm crouching the bushes now i'm watching your every move
welcome to the sun wrong dear i'm not alone
what you have one more sanity point Now you're going to
live.
That map is...
This map is actually so hard.
Come on, Fruit.
Are you my friend?
It's time for you.
Hey, Root, why don't you come into this tent with some
pumpkins?
Actually, oh my god, you're actually...
I thought you were an NPC.
What?
Oh, Fruit.
Wake up!
The skin walkers are here!
Holy crap.
You missed out on this amazing event.
Are you team-backing me?
Yo, dead ass though.
Dead ass though.
There is a tent in there and inside of it are a bunch of
scary ass jack-o'-lanterns.
Wait.
And I was just standing on two feet being like, welcome,
come in.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
That was like the scariest game I've played all year.
That is the...
Yeah, that is the...
a true horror experience it's true i think i have hoop
phobia i'm gonna oh hey that's the title of the game wrong
dear oh it's omelette oh it's amelette oh no i glitched in
the glass again oh no whatever will we do no it's time to
use those apex skills time to shake my ass
Holy crap.
I just saw that.
Worth it.
If you're excuse me, I'm going to retire now.
I'm chewing.
Don't worry.
He's definitely not crawling towards another deer.
I'm just gonna shake.
Oh, he's definitely not crawling to another deer waiting to
get revived.
Nope.
That's not what I'm doing.
He's not doing that.
That's right.
Trader Bill!
Whoa!
The fuck!
The reflex!
Holy shit!
I...
Just keep...
That's right.
Guys, I'm so safe.
Don't worry, I'm so safe.
She is, like, not near me at all.
Guys, I'm in the...
I'm in the river.
Just...
Just start grazing on my body and I'll be okay.
Fruit.
It's gonna be so natural.
Where are you?
Come out, come out, wherever you are.
She can't see me.
I'm in the water.
Are you scared?
Is this terrifying for you?
It's a little bit.
We'll body block.
You remember that scene from Toy Story 1 where all the dead
toys were crawling to save cats.
You're saved now.
I can't get out of the river.
What are you doing?
This one is fruit.
It's me.
I'm fruit.
here I might not have my front legs anymore but I have my
passion you're going crazy looks like we're all fruit here
yeah bro whatever we get on our two legs it's just so
fucking scary it's so scary It's always scary when you're
not looking at the deer, you just hear the footsteps coming
from behind you.
It is so loud too.
You never know which is the right one.
Oh, back, back where it all started.
Going back to school.
That's why we banned all the rules.
Hey guys, how about we give them an education?
What the fuck?
How did you die already?
I was just excited about deer school.
I'm gonna camp your body.
You're a whore.
That's so fucked up.
Get away from me, you freak.
Bro, how could you do that to him?
He's just trying to be a deer.
He's just trying to go to deer high.
He's trying to get an education.
Yeah, he's trying to get a degree.
Get away from me.
I can't believe it.
Now he's going to be held back and it's going to be your
fault.
What will his dear parents say?
Oh.
He has no future.
Get away from me.
I don't like you.
Go away.
Don't give me.
Ain't nobody going to revive you.
Oh shit, did you get there?
Are you limping?
Run!
Save yourself!
No!
Don't be on your own!
I'm falling.
Oh no.
I'm falling off of Lego bridge.
Get behind the tree.
We will do the tree strat.
It's always worked.
Oh fruit.
The tree strat.
Yeah.
Wait, where are you?
I don't know, maybe you should gotcha again.
Maybe you should gotcha.
I'm in your right mood.
Should this be you, bro?
Are we shaking your booty?
I'm shaking my booty.
What of it?
Eh?
Yeah.
Are you entertained?
I am.
Oh, that was perfect.
Whoa, that was perfect.
What the frick?
God damn it, you like, that deer followed me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, come on, fruit, don't be scared.
Oh, I gotta shake my, I gotta shake my ass for a second.
Are you not up?
Sai, you're alive!
You're alive, Sai!
I'm not?
Wait, what?
I'm not alive?
I tried to revive you like two times!
Hey, don't look at me, I'm still flopping around.
I can't believe it.
This is why you flunked out of deer hide.
Why do you think I was trying to get educated?
That's exactly why you flunked out.
Please.
Don't worry.
I got you.
You are...
Yes!
Oh!
Fruit works!
All I'm saying, sigh, is that fruit was an easy red.
Yeah.
I'm not that easy.
Did you ever think about that?
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
It's time.
I want to shoot.
I am.
You did it, guys.
We contributed.
You can actually teabag when you're still out.
It's so funny.
Hey, guys.
I tried to.
I am.
I didn't do shit.
part of the groove yay tiny garden oh no oh no oh tiny
garden please not hunt that please not hunt that oh they got
it any of you say please not hunter you're gonna get hunted
I'm a hunter oh you're going in the corner okay never mind
oh man I see you should a gotcha pool anyone who gets close
to me i'm shooting you should do a gotcha pool yeah do a
gotcha pool so go to your luck yeah test your luck come on i
bet you have good luck do it it's just one shot oh god no i
have the worst luck it's just one shot yeah yeah why are you
scared of one shot come on it's one out of five shots why do
i feel like the one shot is actually going to get
funny if you use that one shot take it take that one shot
right now i gotta take that one shot i knew i knew i was
gonna shoot i'm gonna shoot i knew that was you i should
have shot i should have shot i told you you should have done
it i showed up my look was on my side there it was right
there i mean what's stopping you from taking that shot now
take that shot all right take
Wow.
You almost had me!
What the fuck?
Wait, did my character just say the F word?
How did you get me?
Oh, he's fine.
He's just...
Uh, hey, not to alarm anyone, but, uh, fruit kicked me out
of the map.
Yeah, I think it was, like, bagged up.
Yeah, look at him!
Wait, look at him.
It's so funny.
I'm gonna explore the...
I'm gonna explore the outside world.
No!
Down by... Oh my god.
Are you seeing things?
This is the trippiest shit ever!
I'm falling off!
You like off the map?
Bro, I am literally falling...
He's in a different dimension.
He's in another world now.
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
Did you see that?
Where is he?
A deer just went out to fly suddenly.
Just suddenly went out to fly.
What the frick?
Is he in the sky?
Where is he?
Dude, my body.
He left.
My body is falling.
He's like freaking.
I'm leaving.
See, this is what happens when you let me play a game.
I have the tendency to break these fucking things.
I'm just saying.
I think this game is pretty broken.
Amalia is definitely not heading towards me.
I'm going to head to the bushes.
Yeah, so I can break them all.
Amalia, head to the bushes.
I'm in there.
Head to the bushes.
You stay away from me.
Which one's the real deer?
Man, I sure wish I could see my friends playing the deer
game.
Shouldn't have fallen through the map.
me as i crawl around the floor yep well why you guys do that
oh my god which one are you which one was it uh-oh we're
gonna start standing up we're gonna get our two legs She got
me!
Wow!
Guys, I think the hunter's won.
I fell off the map!
I was signed!
Oh, I didn't know I got you.
We're his size.
He's like roaming the depths.
Dude, I'm in Until Dawn is how far away I am.
I can't believe it.
Bro, fruit has the luckiest gotcha out of all of us right
there.
That was so lucky.
for the well it's time for a paranoid old man there he is
i'm gonna step on your line
you're surrounded that could be that deer right next to you
right now that's right oh look at him the left and right
yeah look at him go i don't i still don't know the Diamonds.
Shooting random things I see.
Do you gotcha pull.
Come on.
Just do a gotcha pull.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
Come on.
If my chat gives subs, I'll shoot blindly right now.
How many gifted subs?
Do the pull.
Maybe you'll get the pity.
Just for five, that'd be fine.
You'll get the pity right there.
I'm crazy.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
I dare you.
I double dare you.
I triple dare you.
Hey, thanks for the five gifted, you'll watch.
Oh!
Well, well!
Okay, your pity is your pity.
You're lucky I'm a match.
That's right, you can't even get me.
You look mad at good and orange.
Ooh, are you going to look at that boulder now?
Whoever comes out of that boulder might be me.
The boulder?
Do we're distracting him?
Go, go, go!
All right, we're moving in.
We're moving in.
Wait, Anneli, are you dead?
Nope.
No, Anneli's just a...
Oh, shit!
It's crouching next to me.
You're lucky I'm a bad shit!
You missed a dead old man!
That's right, I'm an old man.
Oh, damn.
that way bro are you doing that in a different way you i
don't know my kevin freaked out you're in the corner you're
in the corner come on come on that's me over there that's me
okay i that's me Dude, I...
My leg!
Why the fuck?
Bro, I shot three different times.
Chat, you saw that.
My bullets weren't working.
Maybe you're just missing.
Why are you shooting at?
Bro, you're shooting at me!
Shoot again, Andrew!
What are you shooting at?
Wait, is there no deer there for you guys?
There was never a deer there.
Wait, where?
No?
We're shooting at nothing.
One side of the map right now.
Go up to the deer.
Yeah, you were shooting at nothing.
All right, all right, but no one trample me.
Yeah, no problem.
I shot you at different times.
I shot you, Chad.
You all saw it.
I shot that deer, that specific deer.
I shot different times.
I don't know, maybe you were missing.
This game is beyond rigged!
I don't know, maybe you just missed, huh?
Maybe you were missing.
What?
Did he shot you guys?
No, yeah!
He got both of us somehow!
How did he get both of you guys?
Not me!
That's fucking karma, you sons of bitches!
How did he not get me?
We got both of you.
I don't know what it's like.
What the?
Oh, you're just jumping.
For a second, I thought you were levitating.
I was like, oh.
You've got to be fucking kidding me.
You never get me.
I'm like that, what's that whale story?
The moby dick, I'm your moby dick right now.
This is such bullshit.
The walking animation is so funny.
I'm your moving dick!
You'll never catch me!
I'm stuck.
Yo, I get- bro.
I don't know what it is.
No!
I'm not close.
I got you, you so bitch!
I am telling you I shot you Five different times Just get
good What can I just get good Hi Are you ready?
Back where it started You want this to be LG Oh Okay Is that
sigh again Oh I'm not gonna live this shit down, fellas.
LG on site, let's go!
Life begins after school.
That's where we've been.
Oh, the room.
Time to hang with all my friends.
And they're there, I'm shaking my booty for you.
Just like deer hide.
The place where- My throne has how much screaming I did,
holy crap.
The place where we boomed.
long.
He didn't get the good pull.
Mirza, you were scared?
Yeah, why are you so scared?
Don't make me jump on top of my RV.
Get down from the RV, old man.
You're gonna break your back.
You're awfully close.
Shoot him.
That's me.
Shoot it.
Take the shot.
Oh!
Now you'll never know if that one if any other deer is gonna
be me now now you never know you see that deer over there
that you're looking at take the shot take the shot that's me
and take a shot do it that's me right there yeah do it come
on you know you want to take the shot that deer you're
looking at take the shot you should have taken the shot
where did you go got one shot when you got one shot at deer
high oh my god Hey, that deer, that's really close to you.
Take the shot.
Take it.
Come on.
Take the shot.
That's me right there.
Come on.
I'm losing my goddamn mind here, fellas.
Take that shot.
That deer, that's me right here.
All right, man.
Move it.
Take the shot.
Come on.
You know you want to.
You should have taken the shot when you had to.
No!
You took the shot.
One of you motherfuckers left.
Oh, now you're going crazy.
Oh, you!
Yeah!
Yay!
Wait, you're like slow and you're like on your...
Oh my god.
He took this shot.
He actually did it.
I don't know about you, but yeah, this is so much fun.
It was amazing.
I love this game.
This is what this game is.
They got to increase the player, like palliative size.
That would be so fun.
The player size and like more maps.
I think it would be so fun.
It's still early access.
I definitely liked the imposter one the most.
That one was my favorite game though.
That one's the best.
And GG's.
Thank you for joining me.
Yeah, super fun.
GG's.
Yeah, I had a great time.
I'd never laughed so much in my life.
I know.
It was super chaotic.
And then my favorite part was just making a sigh so fucking
paranoid.
Well, it worked.
You know, I like looked at you.
I hope you have wonderful dreams.
I was like so close to you for so long, but you never took
the shot.
I do.
She was saying take the shot.
That was actually her the whole time.
You look so happy.
Oh, my dog.
Oh, also 650.
Yeah, great game.
GGs, GGs.
Thank you, everybody.
Thanks for having me.
I'll see you guys later, guys.
Bye-bye.
Oh, my God.
That was so fun.
I'm glad to be able to try out this game.
Yeah, this is early access.
When the game first came out, it was like the game, when the
game first came out, it was just like no multiplayer.
servers or private servers so like i was like waiting when
it saw that they finally had private servers i was like oh
my god it's gonna be so fun um i definitely enjoyed the
imposter one the most that one was so fun that was just so
fun with all the deer yeah i'm glad to be able to try it out
guys and i hope you guys had fun um i had fun with uh Sai,
Amaline, and Fruit.
I had a great time with them.
Let me swap screens real quick.
Oh, my God.
I laughed so much and screamed so much.
My voice is dying already.
Holy shit.
But yeah, guys, did you guys see the new emotes?
Did you guys see the new emotes?
I added more, these are all like placeholder emotes until
like I actually have new emotes.
I haven't like commissioned any new emotes yet because I
want to wait until I'm waiting until like we have um we have
our new skin suit because i don't want to commission them
and then be like oh shit now i have to like redo all my
emotes so that's why we haven't got them yet hey thank you
for the super chat thank you i only tune in for an hour but
that was so much fun thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i'm glad you guys enjoyed it guys um uh but i'm
thinking the super chat thing you guys cries in european
time so i'm thinking the super chat thing thank you but
that's like the hardest part about streaming just like um
just like make trying to find like times for everybody that
will work for everyone that's why we like redid our um um
change our schedule line up a bit to have it today instead
of tomorrow because uh it fit everybody's schedule because i
was like oh my gosh we if we play this one we should have a
full party because uh um obviously it's gonna be more
chaotic and it'll be more fun to have jesus thank you for
the super chat thank you jesus can you like uncopyright
strike my charity stream jesus can you can you tell the
church to remove the copyright claim so i can like
the placeholders are beautiful too i can't wait for the new
skin suit and emos thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you uh uh works thank you the super chat thank you
thank you don't you please i saw that and i was like oh
sorry we got too into the game and we forgot to introduce
ourselves thank you super chat thank you thank you jordan
this reminds me of the time i went hunting you know the
super chat thank you thank you yeah if your hunting trip is
like that you might need to go to the doctor so you might
need to you might need to get yourself checked Think of the
super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Very, very accurate hunting simulator.
Uh, Galeo.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Your mom.
Um, not so Deadpool.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Hoot Davish for democracy.
I think my favorite part was just the 360.
The three.
Every time I was just.
I was using movement on everybody with the, with the 360
jump.
it's just the 360 like oh you can't catch me you can't catch
me
360 no dear what thank you the super chat thank you thank
you is ketchup a sauce or a gravy it's a sauce um uh toast
thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you
another stream for this game that was hilarious i laughed so
much thank you the super chat thank you thank you i think
like um i'm definitely in the future for this game i'm gonna
wait until there's more uh there's more like modes to it and
more like maps and stuff because like it's definitely a
one-off this is uh this is definitely a one-off game because
um at a point it gets it gets old if we play it too long uh
yeah but there's more content in there it'd be definitely be
more fun um code thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i was surprised that you didn't run when the
hunter was looking away so that they would be more paranoid
when they hear hooves and stop after a bit thank you the
super chat thingy thank you i was like i was tempted to just
like say next like run around him and just stay there
uh where's thingy the super chat thingy thank you um let's
see where was i uh uh oh my god thank you the super chat
thingy thank you this is my first ever super keep up the
good work.
Yes, don't worry.
Saying my username wrong, don't worry.
I read half your username.
Oh, shit.
I forgot to put up the text that I'm reading.
Donation.
It's super chat reading time.
Zonerman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Despite being native, I've never been hunting.
So thanks for showing me part of my heritage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do not worry.
experience guys for those who've never guys i can i bet you
i have some vouchers in my chat this is how hunting is all
about guys this is this is a true hunting experience like if
you're if the deers don't stand up on their two feet that's
not real hunting you gotta watch out for those skin walkers
they're right there
one of us.
It's like that adventure time, that adventure time, uh, uh,
deer meme where he takes off his hose and he's like, man.
Uh, uh, Wayne, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm in Europe.
Night shift lets me watch.
Yeah.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Yeah.
Trying to get like, I always have like a very consistent,
uh, stream schedule.
So most of like 5 p.m p.m.
p.m.
and if i collabs with people on the other side of the world
obviously it's going to be a little later um so i do try to
keep it very consistent um but i do apologize for people on
the other side of the world because uh it's not it's my
streams for them is like super early in the morning so like
i do apologize for that my usual streams uh let's see Thank
you.
Only the tomato skin is expensive, not the skin.
See, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
But speaking of, like, streams on the other side of the
world, streams for the people on the other side of the
world, I would be collabing next week with Ditto, Uto, and
RPR, I think.
We're doing Lethal Company next week.
I think we are.
We're still setting that up, but I assume it was supposed to
be this week.
But there's so many stuff happening for me this week.
that um we decided to move it to next week so um we're still
deciding the day and the time but we'll be playing lethal
company for next week uh yeah that's i think that's i mean
it's really hard because like i try to organize i try not to
like stuff so the thing about this was like i'm planning on
doing a stream talking about like how i my mind works when
it comes to streaming but like um the best advice i can give
people is that this like a sneak peek to this like the
stream that i'm planning that i've been writing notes for
about like um making not just vtubing but like content
creation but like um i try not to put too many collabs in
one week but if there is a lot of collabs in for a week i
balance it out with more solo streams um because you don't
want to have two more collabs than uh solo streams and it's
more so like um you try to do for me right now my for me
right now I try to have like at least one to two collabs a
week just to get started.
I think you might notice that this is a similar pattern when
I first started streaming.
When I first started, not first started streaming, but when
I first started being serious with streaming, when I kicked
things off, because when you're first starting out, you have
to get your name out there.
So like collabing is a great way to do that.
And, um, and so, you i had like a whole thing where i was
like every week i would like to have at least one collab
just to get my name out there and to like uh make people
know who i am because i was new i was new in the basically
new in the world uh so like because like now i'm restarting
my career again so that's why i try to make sure like every
week i have at least one to two collabs um if i collabs i
have like something like you know the tournaments or
something because that's considered a collab um so it's more
so of like uh like every week i want at least one collab
with someone um and it's good to to like networking uh and
despite me being an introvert i try my best to socialize as
much as I can
Chris, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, I
couldn't be more proud of you on your new journey, I can't
have I tried, can't wait to 100% my Doki, you'll never,
you'll never 100% your Doki shrine, but you can try, you can
have 99% because you'll never beat me, it'll never be 100%
because you'll never beat me, keep doing your best, thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you i can't
really wait for the intro to clap again is it coming is
still coming soon um i'm just uh it is soon tm soon tm i
don't have really have any updates other than the last time
i showed it oh sean thank you for the magenta super thank
you thank you it was a great game it was funny especially
the dear fovea thank you for the super chat thank you for
the magenta super thank you thank you i really appreciate
thank you But yeah, I think like right now, Osai, welcome to
the Tomei!
Thank you!
Thank you for joining us, I hope you had a great time being
paranoid now.
Now you trust me less.
I could be right behind you right now.
Um, uh, what was I saying?
Oh yeah, I think the hardest part about, also like the
reason why I've been like trying to like reach out to as
many different people as possible uh to collab is that i
want to try and find like i want to have like a consistent
group to have and so like if i ever want to do more group
collabs i can easily like hit people up for it because
there's a lot of group games i really really want to do like
i want to do like trouble in terraced town again and stuff
like that so I want to get to know as many people as
possible in the community and um and because like you know
it's harder as an indie I think to have a consistent group
of people to to play with and a consistent group of people
to like hit up and stuff to play and like the thing is I
have a lot of people I know and a lot of people I'm friends
with outside uh like not just like in the indie VTuber scene
not just in a vtuber scene but like outside of vtuber scene
but like the risky part is like mixing that group of people
so like i want i always try to keep it consistent like oh
like vtuber collabs and then out collabs outside mix collabs
and stuff like that so um uh and like uh expand my network
and meet as many people as possible so i can have like
consistent people i want to do collabs with or like want to
do group games because like there's so many fun multiplayer
games that I really really want to do and I want to have
like a group like people I can hit up on easily be like you
want to do this game you want to do that game um so a lot of
people I'm like interacting with for the first time or like
uh haven't interacted really much before never had a chance
to collab with so it's it's a lot my social battery
my best anyway i'm gonna read like three more super chats
and i'm gonna call it here because i need to rest my voice
for tomorrow because we do have a stream tomorrow um let's
see uh oh yeah by the way by the way um tempo confirmed to
me that because i made it to the finals i can't participate
in the other tournaments i only go straight to the final
tournament i'm like no i was like i should have thrown but
then i like bracket i'm joking I was like, I should have, I
should have threw my game.
Bracket, I'm joking.
Bracket.
I was like, no, I really wanted to do the third.
I really wanted to do the third one.
The third one looked so fun.
But the finals, they have it too.
No, the free money.
But were you serious about joking?
Navi, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, I really appreciate it.
I always get, like, a lot of anxiety right before the
collab, because, like, obviously, like, when I'm collabing,
even if it's, like, what people I'm, like, used to collabing
with, like, if it's, like, a ditto collab or something,
like, I still get a lot of anxiety right before, like, an
hour before the collab.
I just need you guys to know, when I woke up, I ate lunch,
and then I took a four-hour nap right before the stream.
I literally woke up at like 4.30.
I was so stressed out.
I was just like really tired.
I was just like, all right, wake up, food.
Oh wait, brush teeth, food.
And then I was like,
and then I was like, okay.
And then my dad was like, Doki, it's 4.
It's 4.40.
Wake up!
I was like,
okay I did it I did it um I was getting really nervous
because the thing about collabs is that um versus a solo
stream is that you can't control what happens in the collab
you don't know what's gonna happen you don't know what the
chemistry is gonna be like especially with people you don't
you've never played with before so it's more so like oh you
don't know what the chemistry is gonna be like you don't
know what the uh what the uh what the game is going to be
like if it's a new game you never played with before and all
that stuff so i always get super anxious right before the
collab i know it doesn't look like it like you know fake it
till you make it that's like my whole thing my entire
streaming career has been majority fake it till you make it
because like people don't know i'm an introvert when i first
started and it's like no i'm a full-on introvert i am but
like i'm very good at faking it
so so yeah anyway i'm gonna go call it here guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you sit up for me head to
bed deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye